this might be the future of computing
this is what the world could look like
with magic leap a new technology which
stands to upend the way we work
communicate and play we've created a
digital light field signal that mimics
how the world
the visual part of the world like really
interfaces or talks to your brain roni
above it's a CEO of magic leap the
secretive startup making synthetic
digital images like this that merge with
real spaces the company isn't in Silicon
Valley New York or even Austin it's in
southern Florida
that's why heavy hitters from tech
entertainment and the arts regularly
make the pilgrimage to their Fort
Lauderdale offices to be wowed by the
magic leap experience
you probably don't really get it until
you actually do it Google has invested
CEO sundar pichai sits on the board and
earlier this year
Alibaba led a 794 million dollar
investment part of possibly the largest
C round in history all that and we still
don't know that much about magic leap
but wired has an exclusive early peek
you've heard of ER you've heard of AR
well Roni is working on something that
he calls mr mixed reality that's a way
of tricking the brain to think that
digital light signals made in magic leap
goggles are as real as the world around
us so how does magically do it your
brain is like a graphics processor and
we basically tried to clone what that
signal is we made a digital version of
that and we talked to the GPU
of the brain wired tried it and it is
amazing mountains appear to grow out of
tables and schools of jellyfish float on
ceilings but magically wouldn't let us
show you any more than this inside their
Florida offices robots are calibrating
optics engineers are brainstorming games
and deals with studios are being
hammered out talking about demonstrates
live sports all to bring Ronnie's vision
to reality and to the rest of us at the
heart of the technology is this
photonics chip whatever you do don't
call it a lens magically won't and it
says it won't disclose what the final
goggles will look like or even if their
goggles
it's a three-dimensional wafer like
component that has very small structures
in it and they manage the flow of
photons that ultimately create a digital
light field signal sounds complicated
doesn't it even the people building this
technology have a hard time explaining
what it is and what it's like to
experience it this might sound a little
strange but I think it's like dreaming
with your eyes open
you're just so convinced that what
you're seeing in front of you that you
know is sort of unreal you know that
it's it just it feels so real I think of
the the metal and chrome that we make is
awesome right I mean it's reflects
photons and your retina does all these
crazy crazy awesome things but the most
important thing the most important thing
is what happens when you put it on
magically its potential for gaming and
entertainment is obvious but Roni is
already thinking about how it might
replace all of our other screens too so
I can conjure a tablet I can conjure or
many televisions I can conjure a home
theater but it could be a while before
magic leap conjures up its first product
a wearable the company won't commit to a
release date and there's competition
like Metta and microsoft's hololens
which are already shipping developer
kits roni doesn't mind he's willing to
wait until magic leap is perfect then he
says computing in space will feel
completely natural that to me is the
real magic leap like you've you crossed
through the looking-glass you're on the
other side and there's talking white
rabbits and alice's there and it's it's
pretty cool or maybe it's jellyfish
pulsing across the ceiling for now
you'll have to take a magic leap of
faith
you
[Music]